the way the universe kind of works is
that it's generous the more you give
away the more you get which makes no
logical sense whatsoever
but it's so reliable that you can live
your life based on that but being able
to give away knowing that you'll get it
is the foundation of all artistic
creation
and the best Habit to have because you
need to produce a lot you need to give
away a lot and keep making things in
order to make something great and if you
are confident that there's more where
that's come from you can keep giving
that away and that's how you arrive your
understanding of yourself if we can
create one percent more than we destroy
every year
[Music]
then we can have progress